this canopy mouse is enjoying the
bountiful benefits of living in a
tropical rainforest where food is
plentiful and you can drink right out of
a flower of course there is the
occasional mouse devouring boa to worry
about the Boas clicking tongue tastes
the victims presence the BOA has a mouse
trapped high on a limb with no way out
as the BOA moves in for the kill the
mouse seems to be doomed how can our
plucky hero ever escape this impossible
trap
spreading its limbs like a parachute the
mouse crashes through the foliage
hurtling the equivalent of six storeys
to earth no human could survive a fall
like this but the mouse well it's as
fresh as a daisy your next flight should
have a landing this soft